this program is brought to you by Emory
University clearly the major issue that
Europe is facing right now that affects
us as well is the budget crises and the
difference of Europe and this is
obviously in the news a lot but the
differences are that the nature of the
eurozone and the way it was created
means that ultimately the pressure is on
Germany the real issue is that most of
the funding that is going to bail out
first it was Greece then Ireland then
Portugal it looks like now Italy's and
some problems in Spain maybe shortly
thereafter the and now even yesterday's
conversation was about France and the
French French banking system it's the
Germans that ultimately are paying for
this and the question is how long will
the Germans pay they wouldn't overtly
refuse immediately because that would
bring the eurozone down and it's it's
there's never it's a there's no
precedent for this so it's very
difficult to see what is clear is within
the context of the eurozone in the
European Union fiscal policy has to be
addressed the balancing of budgets the
the excess spending the going into debt
by all of these countries except for
Germany is reliant on German will to
continue at this and it's very very
clear that the vast population that the
vast majority of people in Germany at
the in terms of in terms of questions
surveys are clearly indicating the
German people are getting tired of this
it really is hitting hard now with the
fiscal policy and it countries like
Greece may in fact ultimately the answer
may in fact become they need to move out
of the eurozone well that's what we need
to watch closely because we they would
need to make sure it doesn't have some
type of domino effect looking at what
happens to Greece do they do they leave
the eurozone may be an indication of how
you could or could not begin some type
of limiting the size of the eurozone are
scaling back the size of the year is a
exiting it's like war it's like anything
else it's a lot easier to get into than
it is to get out of
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University